it's good to be Black Panther oh yeah  when the clock strikes midnight the  claws come out in Wakanda I would say  we'd start off I have a bike ride over  the waterfall we're gonna step town but  we had to have guards to make you feel  like nobody's with us get some food some  grilled meats some sit-down afro-cuban  jazz looking at the sunset and we're  kinda nice to have a picnic I think you  take a breath for a second and take a  look at the view taking this one second  is you always have to get to know a  person but the ladies of Wakanda have  something else in mind  some spear sparring little ride on the  vibranium train I'm sure there's great  barbecue in  you